Jeffrey Davis, Writer/Professor: I
gave you a good lead in didn't I?
Peter Desberg, Writer/Professor/Psychologist:
I’m going to tell a different story.
Peter: Oh okay?
Film Courage: We've done two of the
three elements of a Hollywood pitch,
hook and log line now we have three act
structure. Can you talk about that please?
Peter: Sure hit it.
Jeffrey: You hit it.
Peter: No, no, no.
Jeffrey: Well let's assume that you're in a
meeting and you get through the hook and you
get through the log line and now you're sitting
there, you're discussing you're trying to fill
it in and you make an appointment for three to
four weeks ahead and they ask you come back with
a fully fleshed out three act structure you might
get lucky and do it that day I rather doubt it
executives are busy come back now you've
got the setup which is the first act
the the main the conflict which is always
in the second act and then a very short
I think short third acts what we've found
are the best and that's the resolution
and everything builds just like and I think
the great example in The Odd Couple is
in the film I forgot how it was done on the stage
so long ago that I saw it but they're on the roof
and and Walter Matthau playing Oscar says to
Felix I can't take it anymore I'm going crazy
you gotta go and and and and Jack Lemmon says
in other words you're throwing me out and
Walter Matthau says not in other words those are
the perfect ones right and now we're in act three
because it's as high as you can go in the conflict
and what happens in the third act is oh and Felix
leaves saying where I go when I do it'll be on
your head he puts the curse on him that's the
that's that great detail in the top of
the bottom of the second act and and then
the third act is all about Oscar worrying
about where Felix is and if he's okay and
and if you're pitching you don't tell the ending
of the third act and unless you've sold it
and or they've optioned it and then
you have to work out the full story
it's not an outline people think it's an
outline that comes later if you're lucky
but it's much more filled in and has real details
so that we get to know who the characters are
what peter did which I thought was really
great I’d like to take credit for it but
I didn't have anything to do with it is
he said I’ll bet you he said to me when
we were writing I don't know the fourth or
fifth draft that we can make this structure
applicable to anything and he created three acts
as you see in the book for an app a food app and
I would let him tell you about that because
that's his but what I think what I'm saying
is I think that structure of rising conflict
and resolution are applicable to anything and
what's important business is just as in drama
you're trying to solve a problem for somebody
so I gave you a good lead in didn't I I'm going
to tell a different story oh okay how rude of you
I had this fellow come in
stage fright guy and he said
I graduated from Stanford I work in an investment
bank and every week I'm giving a new company to
research and I have to present it to the
board to see if they want to invest in it
we have a bunch of venture capitalist types
and I get so scared I'm on the fast track
everybody that does what I do was really smart
graduated from top schools very competitive
and basically I'm throwing out the stream of
numbers to glazed over eyes and it's horrible
so I said why don't we try three act structure
here so act one as jeffrey was saying is the setup
here you get the background of the company
and the major stuff they're trying to do
what their position is etc act two the really
important part where you set up the conflict
here are the parts and the structure of the
business that may be a problem that may not
here's the upside here's the downside and then
three the resolution here's my recommendation
and the first thing that he noticed was all of
a sudden everybody's sitting forward listening
and he said the thing that amazed him the
most is he threw out two-thirds of the numbers
because he said if the number doesn't
move the story forward I don't need it
I just used to regurgitate numbers but now
the numbers are the data carrying the story
having everything make sense I'm giving
them fewer numbers that are more important
and helping them lead to a better decision and
so if we don't tell the ending of a screenplay
if we if we leave out the resolution what are we
doing with a business pitch again you're doing
the same thing you're sort of leading them to
well here's your upside here's your downside
but this is morphing into another area area
we love which is the psychology of persuasion
because there's interesting there's a whole
field now of behavioral economics that's come
up in the last few years and one of the things
that we know is when people make decisions
you can make a decision from an optimistic
point of view of look at all the cool things we
can have happen or here are the risks do we want
to take the chance so we can have this happen
and the curves are not equal people are much more
risk-averse than they are optimistic about what
could happen and so as you're doing your third act
you're thinking in terms of if I really want to
push the company to do this I have to show a way
to lower a little bit what that risk might be if
I'm wanting him to be really careful I got to push
that up but I'm hitting a natural tendency to say
not so fast okay so this naturally leads
to what I think gets left out of a lot of
business and show business pitches a pitch is not
a sale it's a conversation so what peter's saying
is that if you leave out some things you leave
room for the imagination and the participation of
the person on the other side of the table who like
peter heller told us manager peter heller that
they're also human beings and
they have ideas and thoughts and
so when you go in and you start selling somebody
and you say this is it right away all of us
as human beings stop whether we say it or we
just think it so really I think one of the
things that we hit very hard about pitching in
the book is even if you don't sell the product
that day they're going to remember you and
maybe they'll have something else that's right
for you and they'll call you back if you're
obnoxious and you insist on everything being
your way it's not going to it's not going
to happen and I think that kind of selling
should be going it should be leaving because it's
Jeffrey bring up a really important point it's the
first time for everything one of the one of the
things that a lot of writers have difficulty with
is receiving notes getting criticisms having
people make suggestions and it's kind of the hey
I'm the writer you're not you're telling me what
to do what are you trying to say here peter and
the word that you use for people to
who do that really is amateur because
a smart writer loves it when somebody's making
comments any sort of comments any suggestions
because that's a sign that you're starting
a creative collaboration with somebody
that they're interested enough in what
you're doing to want to be part of it
which means they have more buy-in you're much more
likely to get a green light and so if you get one
of those it's golden and you want to encourage it
we actually talk about strategies you can use if
they're not making comments to try and elicit them
and again well you've done a project so and so
which we really loved based on that how what would
you do with the situation with where if you had a
character that was in this situation so there
were ways to elicit this sort of collaboration
but again the more it's a conversation in
its two way the better rather than I don't
know many people that that like to be talked at
not counting you two of course sure sure yeah.